[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans sens public bienvenue au
105e salon des maes-de France ici depuis
le parc des expositions de la porte de
versaill à Paris communes attaquées
République menacé c'est le thème de ce
congrès des mères on y reviendra avec
mes invités les agressions d'élus et
parfois de leur famille les émeutes de
l'été dernier mais aussi les relations
avec Emmanuel Macron alors que le
président de la République ne sera pas
présent cette année ce sera le thème de
notre premier débat et puis euh juste
après c'est un gros plan sur les enjeux
de transition écologique que je vous
propose les anes les AFE derrière ces
acronymes euh se cache une volonté des
objectifs ambitieux mais aussi un
casse-tête pour les élus zéro
artificialisation nette zone à faible
émission comment concilier croissance et
urgence environnementale on en débat
dans 45 minutes mais d'abord le ralbol
des maires de France constaté par une
enquête du svipov que nous détaille
Jonathan dupriz et Fabien RER commune
attaquée République menacée l'intitulé
du 105e congrès des maires annonce la
couleur des milliers d'dy usés fatigués
par un enchaînement de crise se
réuniront Porte de Versailles ces
prochains jours mais ils n'auront pas
l'occasion de faire remonter leur
doléance à Emmanuel Macron retenu par un
G20 s remarqué mais balayé par le
président de l'AMF il est pas obligé de
venir tous les ans au Congrès des mes
moi j'ai toujours dit c'est lui qui
avait dit qu'il virait tous les ans mais
demandait pas donc je vais pas moi à
chaque fois tous les ans devoir parler
de la venue ou pas du président sur le
fond les mairres vont aborder de
nombreux sujets dont certains sont
alarmants comme les agressions envers
les élus dans un contexte où les maires
ont été très exposés pendant les émeut
elle pourrait croître de 15 % d'ici à la
fin de l'année par rapport à 2022 une
année des jà record dans les través du
salon peu nombreux sont les maires à ne
pas avoir vécu de situation tendu avec
des administrés il nous a menacé de
morts à plusieurs reprises on a on sait
que lors d'un conseil municipal j'étais
obligé de faire venir la gendarmerie
pour nous escorter pour pour nous
protéger il a agressé un des voisins
parce qu'il s' prenait aussi aux voisins
et grâce grâce à cause de cette
agression il a pu être mis au tribunal
et il a pris un enferme et 3 an
d'indiction de revenir sur la commune
sur tous les sujets tous les fronts les
maires se retrouvent en première ligne y
Pora le sa bien depuis plusieurs années
ce maire des Pyrénées Orientales fait
face à une problématique de sécheresse
très inquiétante sécheresse synonyme
d'accroissement du risque incendie il y
a les obligations légales de
débrousaillement l'État aussi s'implique
mais à aujourd'hui à aujourd'hui ça
reste insuffisant et je pense qu'avant
tout je suis pas le seul à le dire il
faudrait carrément revoir la loi
concernant les obligations de
débroussailler les parcelles d'autres
sujets seront abordés durant ce le
Congrès comme la baisse des dotations le
zéro artificialisation nette ou encore
la surabondance de normes face à cette
action locale de plus en plus difficile
à mener les élus n'hésitent plus à jeter
l'éponge selon une étude du cvipof avec
l'AMF 1300 maires auraient démissionné
depuis 2020 voilà avec toutes les
équipes de de Public Sénat on s'est
installé ici au au cœur du du Congrès
des Maires juste à côté du du Grand
Auditorium où se déroule la plupart des
des conférences majeures et il y a du
monde il y a de l'emblance pour pour
nous suivre pour nous écouter et
certains de ces élus sont évidemment sur
notre plateau j'accueille Franck
louvriux bonsoir bonjour il fait encore
jour je regarde là il y a encore la
lumière du jour bien bienvenue à vous
vous êtes maire et l'air de la ble
vice-président de la Région des Pays de
la Loire Fanny chapé bienvenue vous êtes
maire socialiste de pinpul dans les
Côtes d'Armor conseillère délégué au au
logement de la région Bretagne Benjamin
Morel bienvenue à vous aussi
constitutionnaliste maître de conférence
en en droit public
Paris de Panthéon àas et vous publiez à
la France en miette aux éditions du SER
et laéticia crupa éditorialiste
politique bienvenue à vous laetia je
reprends pour commencer certains des des
chiffres de cette enquête du cvipov pour
pour la MF 450 démissions de maire
chaque année depuis le mois de juin 2020
et quand on demande à ses élus les
causes des démissions les voici
exigences trop fortes des citoyens c'est
ce qui vient en premier relation
difficile avec l'État forcément on en
parlera dans ce débat monter les
violences évidemment aussi et puis
conciliation des mandats et de la vie
professionnelle Franck Louvrier est-ce
que vous comprenez ces maires ces élus
qui démissionne et est-ce que vous
partagez parfois leur rbol est-ce que ça
vous arrive de vous dire wouh pourquoi
je fais ça encore parce que j'ai encore
le le sentiment que je suis utile mais
le fait est c'est que je comprends
parfaitement c'est cette perte de de
repères de la part des maires parce qu'à
un moment donné ils se sentent seuls
c'est sont les derniers fantassins de la
République et on devrait justement
apporter un soutien permanent si ce
n'est très important à leur endroit
quelle que soit la l'importance de leur
commune parce que je crois aussi à ça
c'est que c'est grâce à ces dizaines de
milliers de communes qu'on arrive à
faire vivre notre République et et donc
par a pas trop des communes 36000 c'est
pas parce que c'est vraiment une
tradition marquant en France he on a pas
ça dans tous les pays il une tendance au
regroupement moi dans ma région des Pays
de la Loire la région du Mené Loire par
exemple regroupe de beaucoup de de
communes mais mais je crois qu'il faut
laisser justement les les maires gérent
ça parfaitement bien ils savent le faire
ils savent quand est-ce qu'ils ont
besoin de pouvoir se regrouper ou quand
est-ce qu'ils peuvent rester de façon
indépendante mais mais au-delà de ça
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que
aujourd'hui les maires sont pas toujours
considérés comme les principaux
interlocuteur de l'État je trouve que on
devrait avoir beaucoup plus de fluidité
entre les autorités préfectorales les
maires et et et d'une façon ou d'une
autre les autorités qui peuvent être la
gendarmerie ou la police par exemple
dans dans le domaine de la sécurité on a
vraiment là le sentiment que d'une façon
ou d'une autre ils sont plus que les
seuls repères vous savez à une époque
dans dans les villes ou dans les
villages vous aviez d'autres pères le
médecin le notaire les le je dirais les
institutionnels aujourd'hui il y a plus
que le maire donc le maire il faut
vraiment le supporter dans le sens
l'aider ou fan chapé vous avez répondu à
cette enquête du du cvipof pour faire
passer quel message
prioritaire déjà j'ai participé à
l'enquête parce que je corresponds pas
au profil type des maires on est plutôt
sur un profil type homme de 60 ans donc
voilà je voulais aussi apporter mon mon
non je regarde pas Fran désolé regarde
j'allais le dire jeais pas vous demander
votre 68 non mais pourquoi parce que je
voulais aussi apporter mon mon
témoignage parce que ce dont on ne parle
pas non plus on parle effectivement de
la conciliation avec la vie
professionnelle mais il y a aussi la vie
de famille parce qu' aujourd'hui on a
aussi une génération d'élus qui a des
enfants en basage et ça on n parle pas à
mon avis assez aussi dans les
difficultés que les mères peuvent
rencontrer parce que quand on parle des
agressions quand on parle des insultes
ça touche également l'entourage familial
et parmi les élus qui démissionnent il y
a aussi des jeunes parents qui veulent
protéger leur famille et ça ça paration
conciliation pardon vous interrompre du
mandat et de la vie professionnelle on
l'a vu tout à l'heure est-ce que ça vous
a vous personnellement à amené à faire
des choix à renoncer à certains mandats
ou à certaines responsabilités pour
justement ne pas trop délaisser la vie
la vie personnelle la vie familiale et
bien évidemment parce que quand on veut
exercer de façon la plus consciencieuse
professionnelle c'est manda si on veut
également travailler et si on veut aussi
assurer une vie de famille de qualité
évidemment qu'il y a des choix à faire
et personne n'est capable de le faire
aujourd'hui donc en l'occurrence moi
aujourd'hui j'ai mis de côté ma vie
professionnelle d'accord donc vous vous
êtes à temps plein et mare et maère
c'est joliment dit Benjamin Morel que
dit ce ralbol des mèes de de notre
époque du respect des institutions
Franck Louvrier le le parlait mais
peut-être aussi des des citoyens qui se
comportent de plus en plus comme des
consommateur alors ça dit beaucoup de
choses en effet hein alors il faut
peut-être pas avoir une vision quand
même trop franco-française de la chose
on voit qu'on a une montée de la
violence contre les élus partout en
Europe hein je répète souvent mais deux
députés ont été assassinés ces dernières
années en Grande-Bretagne un préfet en
Allemagne des maires également en Italie
donc on voit qu'on a une violence qui
est aujourd'hui profonde et dont les
élus qui apparaissent en effet comme
étant ceux en lien direct à la fois avec
la population et en même temps incarnant
les institutions incarnant pour le maire
et l'État et la collectivité sont les
premières victimes le maire ben c'est
celui comme aime bien le dire àard aime
bien le dire Gérard Larcher qui est à
porté de BAFF celui que vous pouvez
rencontrer celui auquel vous pouvez vous
adresser et qui donc se faisant étant
l'élu premier sur le terrain souvent va
être la première victime de ces
violences de ces attaques après sur
l'autre front on a des mares qui par
rapport à ça se sentent relativement
délaissés d'abord parce que vous avez
une fragilisation du rôle du maire parce
que vous l'avez bien évoqué entre d'un
côté l'intercommunalité de l'autre la
surabondance normative et enfin bah la
suppression de quelques Levi notamment
des leviers fiscaux vous avez un maire
qui apparaît comme étant le réceptacle
des demandes des citoyens mais qui en
même temps a une marge de manœuvre de
plus en plus grévé ces dernières années
et donc et bien cette tension entre d'un
côté les espoirs et de l'autre côté et
bien les marges de manœuvre ça crée à la
fois pour les élus une des espérances
qui aggrav encore ce sentiment d'être le
premier sur la sur la ligne d'attaque al
on essaie de pas être trop binaire dans
ces dans dans nos débats dans dans dans
sens public donc on va quand même
beaucoup parler de ce qui est compliqué
ce qui va mal mais qu'est-ce qui fait
que vous adorez ce ce cette mission de
mère soyons un peu positif tiens Fanny
chapé ben c'est ce que c'est ce que vous
avez dit en fait c'est le sentiment
d'utilité puisque on est alors moi je
dis toujours on est on entend beaucoup
on est à porter de BAFF mais on est
aussi à pter de réponse on est aussi les
interlocuteurs privilégiés on est la
porte d'entrée donc effectivement il y a
ce sentiment d'utilité qui qui nous
anime et ce qui fait que c'est
passionnant c'est que en Ré on
n'intervient pas que sur les compétences
municipales on intervient sur tout on
nous sollicite sur la santé on nous
sollicite sur le logement là dans les
périodes de crise on va nous solliciter
pour avoir des réponses pour soutenir
les agriculteurs on nous sollicite
surtout et c'est ce qui rend
effectivement ce mandat je crois en tout
cas pour ma part passionnant même
question franc l'ouvrier moi moi j'ai
j'ai toujours ce sentiment que le maire
quand il prend une décision il peut il
peut en voir les fait assez rapid VO
exactement d'abord on est des Feurs et
pas des diesurs ou et puis deuxième
chose moi j'ai eu la chance de
travailler auprès d'un président de la
République et dans des cabinets
ministériels et après je suis allé vers
la fonction de ma ce qui est assez rare
en général on va plutôt dans l'autre
sens et et parfois mes mes électeurs me
disaient mais pourquoi tu veux être
maire parce qu'en fin de compte c'est
l'essence même de la politique c'est de
pouvoir prendre des décisions et de voir
leur réalisation quand vous êtes
président de la République en général
vous décidez pour votre successeur à
l'échelle de la région bon voilà et
encore
ais ça met du temps quand vous êtes
président de région c'est pareil les
c'est long les décisions sont longues et
ceetera pour faire un lycée c'est c'est
6 8 ans minimum euh lorsque vous êtes
maire vous prenez une réalisation vous
avez la chance de couper le ruban ou
peut-être de de l'inaugurer et même de
voir vivre vos concitoyens à l'intérieur
de du bâtiment que vous avez décidé avec
votre conseil municipal donc c'est c'est
vraiment avoir l'utilité de la politique
et ça c'est formidable laticia oui je
voulais une vous posz une question à
vous deux tiens est-ce que aux yeux de
vos administrés vous incarnez l'État
comme vous l'avez dit comme vous l'avez
dit Benjamin Morel où est-ce que vous
êtes des l'
est-ce que vous êtes à la verticale ou
est-ce que vous êtes à l'horizontale
vous comprenez ma question oui alors on
nacerme pas du tout l'État en fin de
compte quand on réussit pas les no nos
nos concitoyens disent que c'est de la
faute de l'État on est vraiment
l'interface c'est pour ça que on est
vraiment utile pour le président de la
République et et pour le gouvernement
parce que nous sommes l'interface entre
nos concitoyens et puis les décisions
qui pe être pris au niveau
gouvernemental donc c'est c'est pour eux
c'est c'est la première porte qui est la
plus facile à ouvrir parce que les
autres ils y arrivent pas c'est normal
c'est trop compliqué donc ils savent
ouvrir la porte de la mairie donc et
c'est à ce moment-là qu'arrivve tous les
problèmes F chaap oui il SAV aussi la
refermer parce qu'il y a un certain
dégagisme aujourd'hui et je suis ravi de
voir que je en tout cas de savoir ou
d'apprendre que je veri mes réalisations
mais j'en suis pas certaine parce
qu'aujourd'hui sur la politique du
logement par exemple quand on voit le
temps que l'on va pouvoir mettre à avoir
aboutir une opération moi je suis pas
sûr à moins que je sois réélu c'est tout
ce que je me souhaite je suis pas sûr de
voir les réalisation parce
qu'effectivement ce certain dégagisme il
est aussi lié au fait qu'on ne
représente que nous-même et que si on ne
voit pas aboutir par exemple les
attentes sur le logement sur la santé
sur l'emploi et cetera la crainte qui
est mise aussi par un certain nombre de
maires bah c'est qu'on en soit les
premiers pénalisés ce qui explique
certainement que un de mandats c'est
c'est le maximum que l'on peut espérer
aujourd'hui quo oui sauf que je pense
que le phénomène de zapping qu'on
connaît en politique connaît très
fortement dans la représentation
parlementaire on la connaît moins quand
même dans la fonction de maire
parce que on sait que la fidè d'abord le
mandat est plus long c'est ça compte un
an de plus 6 ans et puis surtout c'est
que il y a une forme de fidélité qui se
fait de proximité qui existe moins avec
un mandat de maire ou même au niveau de
la région ou du département ou ça permet
aussi Benjamin Morel a des partis
politiques qui sont en difficulté dans
d'autres élections de de de garder un un
maillage et une puissance importante en
l'occurrence on en a deux ici le Parti
socialiste ou le parti LR bien sûr parce
que il y a malgré tout une prime sortant
qui est à la fois la reconnaissance d'un
bilan à la notoriété du maire à la fait
que au fait que on lui fait confiance et
le cumul des mandats la fin du cumul des
mandats a créé ce que vous disiez est
très vrai c'est-à-dire que beaucoup de
parlementaires sortant qui cumulaient se
sont dit entre les deux mandats entre
lever la main à l'assemblé et être sur
le terrain et voir le monde se réaliser
parce que et bien je prends un certain
nombre de décisions je préfère la
seconde option et donc dans la fin du
cumul des mandats beaucoup ont choisi
justement de rester encré et aujourd'hui
on assiste en effet à un moment assez
étrange depuis le début de la République
depuis 1870 on n' jamais vécu un tel
décalage entre d'un côté le champ
politique local qui est détenu
essentiellement par la gauche et la
droite traditionnelle LR les centristes
le PS le PC et de l'autre côté le champ
politique national dominé par la
République en marche la fi et le RN donc
on voit ce décalage profond et
aujourd'hui en effet ça peut poser des
problèmes également en terme de
communication entre la base et le sommet
historiquement et je m'arrêterai là il y
a trois grands canaux qui permettent
justement à la base et au sommet de
communiquer cumule des mandats
administration déconcentrée grande
partie en grande partie affaiblie les
partis politiques or ces partis
politiques je l'ai dit tout à l'heure et
bien aujourd'hui sont un peu indvergence
et ça explique également en partie cette
crise aujourd'hui du local et des
rapports avec l'État on va parler
d'argent tiens dans ce débat regardez ce
ce tableau sur les
indemnités touché par les maires on n'
pas mis tous les échelons parce que ce
serait un peu un peu fastidieux euh
nombre d'habitants d'un côté indemnité
maximale brut de l'autre on parle de
moins de 500 habitants avec un peu plus
de 1000 € euh de 3500 à 10000 2250 €
20000 à 50000 3600 plus de 200000 près
de 6000 € euh brut hein évidemment et la
ville de Paris on est à 7008 euh et puis
alors ça me mène à vous donner un autre
élément de l'étude du cvipof comment les
élus perçoivent justement leur
indemnisation est-ce qu'elle est
suffisante 48 % des maires jugent cette
indemnité insuffisante euh c'est 43 %
dans les mes de petites communes c'est
78 % dans les MRES de communes de de
plus de 9000 habitants fan chap pintpul
c'est 7 7000 un peu plus de 7000 7200
habitants combien je c'est une question
très indiscrète mais combien vous quelle
est votre indemnité 1500 1500 à laquelle
on peut rajouter l'indemnité de
conseiller régional c'est ça et et
est-ce que vous dites que c'est pas cher
payé alors pour le coup quand j'ai
répondu à cette enquête je ne fais pas
partie de cm qui considèrent qu'on n'est
pas assez indemnisé par contre moi c'est
ce que je prend c'est un meilleur
accompagnement je reviens je suis désolé
sur le sujet que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure sur la garde des enfants par
exemple finalement c'est pas fluide donc
il y avait la possibilité peut-être de
proposer des accompagnement des voilà
des soutiens en toutous les cas plus
pour concilier cet ensemble maintenant
voilà j'ai aussi la dignité de
conseillère
régional pour le coup ce n'est pas ce
que moi j'attends le plus pour valoriser
valoriser notre mandat de de maire je je
reviens quand même au-delà des
indemnités moi ce qui vraiment
aujourd'hui est très attendu c'est le
soutien de l'État je préfère ne pas
avoir une augmentation de mes indemnités
mais avoir un état plus présent
particulièrement quand on traverse des
intempéries et je crois vraiment et je
veux passer ce message là si l'État
était plus présent ça serait le meilleur
soutien qu'on pourrait avoir on y
reviendra évidemment un peu plus tard
parce qu'on va parler de l'absence
d'Emmanuel Macron dans ce congrès des
des maires Franck Louvrier cette
question des indemnités ça pose aussi la
question des maires qui travaillent à
côté est-ce qu' est-ce qu'il faut être
un maire un temps plein pour être un bon
maire moi j'ai pris la décision d'être
maire à temps plein je ne pouvais pas
faire autrement hein j'ai j'ai 350
personnes dans ma commune euh j'ai 63
millions DEET ça suffit pas non non
c'est pas possible parce que vous
imaginez bien que j'ai une ville qui
fait 18000 habitants qui passe 180000
habitants l'été et qui est surclassé 80
150000 donc je gagne 200400 € comme
maire donc c'est vrai que relativement
ça peut paraître quand vous moi j'étais
dans le secteur privé auparavant les
gens disent mais c'est pas possible
pourquoi tu fais
ça vous aajouterz l'indemnité de
viprésident résident de la région mais
l'indemnité viprésident la rion c'est
aussi des heures en plus parce que faut
pas croire c'est 2 milliards de budget
la région des Pays de la Loire donc
c'est c'est pas rien et donc c'est des
responsabilités supplémentaires donc
quand on dit on cumule les mandats très
bien mais on cumule aussi les
responsabilités et on est écrité d'abord
on peut pas dépasser une certaine somme
donc le fait est c'est que je pense que
surtout les les communes petite et
moyenne devraiêre les Maes devrai être
beaucoup plus rémunéré parce que c'est
autant de temps quasiment vous savez
quand vous avez à gérer une personne
c'est la même quand elle est dans une
commune de 500 habitants que quand elle
est dans une commune de de 250000
habitants donc il faut sans doute porter
plus d'attention mais le problème c'est
que ça fait des années qu'on en parle et
que ça bouge pas c'est ça qui m'exaspère
moi le statut de l'élu je crois que je
le connais depuis que je suis né mais
est-ce que ça a bougé pendant le mandat
de Nicolas Sarkozi don vous étiez l'un
des plus proches oui B non mais c'est
dommage c'est dommage et en plus lui il
savait ce que c'était quê maire parce
qu'il l'avait été et il avait eu des
responsabilités locales mais c'est c'est
c'est vraiment là il faut il faut
prendre alors je sais qu'il y a une
mission qui a été donnée à Eric vert
récemment pour essayer de travailler
notamment sur le cumul des mandats sur
le cumul des fonctions sur les les
superpositions aussi hein parce qu'il y
y a un la décentralisation hein c'est
quand même le thème voil mais il faut
vraiment s'atteler aux choses et pas en
parler la veille du congrès des maires
voilà ouais effectivement vous parliez
de la dotation des dotations de de
l'État Fanny chapé écoutez là-dessus
l'ancienne mare de plopsim elle a alors
ce ce ce témoignage il date d'il y a
quelques années au moment où elle a
choisi de ne pas se représenter elle a
d'une certaine façon démissionné de son
mandat de maire de plopsim on l'écoute
c'est c'est Anne Catherine Weber dans
notre métier on a énormément de pouvoir
mais on a malheureusement pas forcément
les moyens de d'appliquer les les lois
qu'on nous demande de faire respecter
c'est terriblement difficile et
terriblement usant quand on essaie de
faire bien fan chap est-ce que vous
pouvez détailler ce que vous nous disiez
tout à l'heure c'estàdire vous dites moi
je veux pas forcément être augmenté je
veux que les dotations de l'État suivent
sur quel domaine particulier vous êtes
souvent sollicité par vos administrés
alors que vous avez pas forcément le
pouvoir de de d'agir voyez ce que je
veux dire et permettez-moi je peux pas
m'empêcher effectivement les mares des
petites communes ils demandent aussi de
l'ingénierie ce qui rejoint ce que je
disais tout à l'heure un accompagnement
de l'État et c'est pas une augmentation
des indemnités qui rés qui résoudra en
tout cas qui leur permettra d'avoir plus
d'ingénierie et de et de les soulager
typiquement PUL c'est 7200 habitants
mais en soit ça veut rien dire c'est une
ville centre c'est une centralité c'est
une polarité donc voilà on a pour
vocation de rendre un certain nombre de
services au canton donc à l'ensemble des
communes voisines et bien par exemple
les dotations pour les centralités ne
sont FT pas la hauteur des attentes ne
sont pas indexé en fonction de
l'inflation donc on n' pas ce soutien
financier de ville centre que l'on
aurait pu avoir et pour répondre à votre
question bah typiquement il y a deux
sujets sur lesquels nous sommes
interpellés quotidiennement le logement
et la santé sur le logement et la santé
en tant que maire moi je n'ai pas les
moyens de répondre aux administrés je ne
pas j'ai pas la compétence j'ai pas la
capacité je n'ai pas ce pouvoir donc là
effectivement si on avait un soutien
plus fort si on avait un écosystème plus
flu est plus en mesure de répondre en
réactivité et en proximité on pourrait
répondre aux administrés et c'est la
seule chose qui demande qu'on incarne
l'état qu'on incarne nous-mêmes eux ils
s'en fichent ce qu'ils veulent c'est une
réponse et là on n'est pas en mesure de
répondre aujourd'hui sur ce deux C deux
problématiques cette baisse des
dotations Benjamin Morel est-ce que
c'est un un penchant macronien ou une
tendance plus ancienne alors non en
réalité la baisse des dotations Emmanuel
Macron l'a un petit peu corrigé parce
que sous François hollandre ça avait
beaucoup plus baisser en réalité il faut
voir que l'État quand il doit faire des
économies budgétaires ben n'a pas
vraiment la capacité de jouer sur
d'autres leviers que celui-ci surtout
qu'aujourd'hui le budget de l'État était
quand même énormément écrasé mais il
faut bien comprendre que Ben prenez deux
rapports rapport de l'OCDE en 2016
rapport du FMI en 2014 la
décentralisation on peut dire c'est pas
vrai on peut se rolller par terre en
disant c'est pas le cas mais ça produit
des inégalité sauf si vous avez un rôle
de l'État qui en effet va jouer un rôle
d'aménagement du territoire d'appui aux
collectivité d'ingénierie et si vous
avez de la péréquation quand vous
baissez les dotations quand vous enlevez
l'état du territoire vous créez des
inégalit les communes qui sont très bien
dotées qui qui ont de l'argent vont
pouvoir agir les autres vont être
beaucoup plus en difficulté et là on a
en effet commis ces dernières années un
certain nombre d'erreurs qu'on paye
gilets jaunes et cetera le deuxième
élément parce que je voulais tout de
même rebondir là-dessus les indemnités
nos de maires auront peut-être plus de
mal à le dire mais elles sont clairement
insuffisantes on peut pas espérer régler
aujourd'hui le problème des voocations
sans penser ce sujet dans les petites
communes mais même dans les grandes un
exemple les communes de plus de 200000
habitants l'indemnité maximum en France
est inférieure à l'indem unité minimum
pour les communes de même type en
Allemagne et donc ce faisant et bien
forcément vous avez une crise
d'évocation forcément vous avez de la
fragilité il y a pas que ça qui compte
évidemment il y a le pouvoir de faire il
y a l'intérêt général peut-être mais
malgré tout aujourd'hui ça compte parce
que vous ne pouvez pas vous appuyer
toujours sur les mêmes qui vont cumuler
d'année en année des mandats parce que
personne ne veut prendre les rennes de
la commune notamment pour les plus
petites si vous voulez un renouvellement
des élus et je rappelle qu'on en a
500000 en France dont 2 tiers tout de
même sont des conseill municipaux de
communes de moins de 100000 habitants
qui sont purement volontaires si on veut
garder ce tissul et bien il faut penser
tout de même à le reconnaître à
l'indemniser
Emmanuel Macron a choisi de ne pas venir
cette année son ancien Premier ministre
lui était présent ce mardi matin Édouard
Philippe dans les Travis du Congrès des
Maires ben justement tiens il a défendu
Emmanuel Macron on écoute l'ancien
Premier ministre il est pas écrit que le
Président de la République doit venir
chaque fois au Salon des Maires et je
vois bien qu'à chaque fois on essaie
d'en faire une histoire bon voilà
franchement c'est c'est pas très grave
comme ils se promènent beaucoup en
France je suis certain qu'à chaque fois
que les maires le rencontrent ils lui
disent des choses et c'est normal
croyez-moi je suis le premier quand il
vient VO à lui dire un certain nombre de
choses c'est normal c'est la vie c'est
ça se passera toujours comme ça donc il
y a j'ai aucun problème avec l'idée qui
ne viennne pas cette année Laeticia je
me tourne vers vers vous est-ce que
c'est une faute de communication
politique le le fait de ne pas venir de
la part du président de la République
oui c'est une faute de communication
politique parce que personne ne comprend
son choix donc quand vous faites un
choix et que vous êtes président de la
République si personne ne le comprend
c'est un problème
alors de façon officielle il y a quand
même une explication officielle Thomas
oui l'entourage l'Élysée a dit
qu'Emmanuel Macron ne pouvait pas il
devait venir il devait venir demain il
ne peut pas parce qu'il a un agenda
diplomatique qui est très chargé je me
suis permise de regarder son agenda
quand même pour vérifier c'est vrai hier
il recevait l'ex ex-président d'Israël
demain jour de sa venue hein normalement
potentiel il a un G20 en visio mais il
doit être à l'Élysée et puis il reçoit
aussi le président de la Côte d'Ivoire
le problème ce n'est pas cet agenda
chargé c'est que le président ne l'a pas
expliqué ni au maire première politesse
ni au français il aurait pu le faire par
exemple comme il le fait d'habitude sur
X l'ancien Twitter une petite vidéo pour
expliquer pourquoi il ne viendrait pas
et donc l'image qui risque d'être
retenue du chef de l'État c'est celle
d'un chef qui se défusses et qui ne va
pas à la rencontre des él des élus qui
sont les plus appréciés je ne sais pas
si vous allez confirmer les plus
appréciés des Français et qui eux sont
vous l'avez dit Benjamin Morel hein on
le dit souvent c'est rentré finalement
quasiment dans le vocabulaire politique
apporter de BAFF eux le sont il y a le
discours officiel explication officielle
mais au-delà de ça est-ce qu'on sait
pourquoi il a il a fait ce choix de ne
pas venir oui on le sait et le problème
parce qu'il y a encore un problème dans
la méthode Thomas c'est queon l'a appris
dans la presse si vous êtes un grand
lecteur des journaux vous savez tout sur
Emmanuel Macron parce que les
journalistes ont été glanés des vous
savez des petits confidentiels voilà que
l'entourage donne parfois alors dans
politico par exemple euh ce ne sont pas
les maires de France je précise qu'il y
a des guillemets ce ne sont pas les
maires de France qui l'emmerdent mais
l'association des maires de France c'est
dit dans le Figaro on apprend que le
président ne veut pas donner une tribune
politique à David Lisnard et à André
leniel les deux patrons de l'AMF alors
que lui toujours entre guillemets
viendrait parler des problèmes des
maires et quand on écoute un peu et que
on questionne son entourage on comprend
aussi qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a pas du tout
envie d'un accueil hostile et de sifflet
parce qu'il avait été habitué à être
accueilli par des sifflets donc la faute
de communication politique Thomas c'est
que le présent président finalement ne
sera pas entendu les Français vont
entendre les maires or les maires disent
qu'il y a
recentralisation alors que l'exécutif ne
cesse de clamer qu'un processus de
décentralisation est en cours depuis
l'arrivée Emmanuel Macron et d'ailleurs
Eric vert on en parlait tout à l'heure
avec franc Louvrier l'ex-ministre du
Budget est censé mener cette
décentralisation donc le résultat c'est
que toutes les initiatives d'Emmanuel
Macron pour réparer une relation
difficile avec les maire bon B ne vont
pas être visibles des Français et
l'image du chef de l'État va être ternie
alors on va on va revenir sur le fait
qu' il reçoit quand même les un millier
de de d'élus dans demain on va y revenir
avec vous latitia mais un un mot Franck
Louvrier c'est vrai que vous étiez en
plus le directeur de la communication de
de Nicolas Sarkozi est-ce que vous
comment vous analysez la l'absence du
président de la République ici est-ce
que c'est une erreur de communication
mme si Nicolas Sarkozy aimait beaucoup
les maires il n'est pas allé à chaque
foisou comme il est pas allé non plus
tous les ans salon de l'agriculture
parce que sur un mandat il est normal
que vous soyez pas présent à chacune des
manifestations il y a un premier
ministre il y a aussi un gouvernement ça
c'est la première chose il est allé
combien de fois et là là où là où vous
avez raison dans dans votre édito et et
c'est qu' faut pas que ce soit
interprété comme une stratégie de
l'évitement et et c'est là toute la
difficulté on a eu ce cas d'école
malheureusement sur ce qui s'est passé
lors du rassemblement contre
l'antisémitisme et pour la République et
il faut justement expliquer pourquoi et
puis maintenant il y a des technologies
qui permettre aussi de faire passer des
messages nous élus il nous arrive de pas
être à toutes les manifestations et
parfois on envoie une petite vidéo un
petit message de la de la part de notre
adjoint la première ministre pourrait
lire par exemple un message du président
de la République en disant voilà est-ce
qui qu' on peut comprendre parce que son
agenda international le G20 ça prend
énormément de temps et et et ça donc
voilà mais je je pense qu'il faut
l'expliquer c'est et c'est là tout le
bon sens de cet édito c'est c'est donner
euh une explication à une chose qui
peut-être évidente et qui peut être
compris par tout le monde je crois pas
que le Président de la République sera
sifflé vous savez les maires sont des
républicains ils ont pas non plus envie
d'être sifflés quand ils sont dans des
manifestations ils ne siffleront pas le
président de la République ouais et donc
le président de la République reçoit un
millier de d'élus demain comment passer
latia est-ce qu'on aura des images
comment qu'est-ce qui est prévu bah le
problème ça aurait pu rattraper son
absence finalement de recevoir un
milliers de mer le problème Thomas il y
a encore un problème c'est que ce n'est
pas du tout un événement il le fait
chaque année donc on commence à s'y
habituer et puis peut-être qu'il aurait
pu en faire un objet de communication
politique en ouvrant les portes de
l'Élysée en faisant rentrer les caméras
les photographes en immortalisant ce
moment pour le moment ce n'est pas prévu
hein pour l'instant on reste tous dehors
donc il y aura peut-être quelques images
d'arrivée mais finalement il l'a laissé
entendre oui il en fait un peu un
argument qui vient contrer son absence
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit aussi
fort donc le problème aussi c'est que
c'est noyé dans un balai des maires qui
se déplacent de ministère en ministère
ce soir c'est Bruno Le Maire qui les
reçoit à à Bery il y aura aussi Gérald
haranin qui laiss attend et puis la
première ministre vous avez raison alors
déjà c'est elle qui va faire le discours
de comme l'année dernière jeudi et puis
dans la foulée elle attend les m à
Matignon donc vous comprenez bien
leseffet ça fait pchite finalement déjà
avant même que qu'Emmanuel Macron ait
reçu et donc la conclusion c'est que
finalement Emmanuel Macron risque de
rester englué dans cette position
verticale dont il n'arrive pas à sortir
h et donc coupé de des ambassadeurs des
Français qui sont les maires et donc
couper de ses ambassadeurs couper de la
base et couper de son peuple Fanny
chappé est-ce que vous irez demain soir
à l'Élysée mais final alors première
chose quand même j'entends depuis tout à
l'heure à plusieurs reprises que il
n'est pas obligé de venir chaque année
certes mais commune attaqué République
menacée je trouve que l'intitulé est
suffisamment fort quand même et qu'il
mérite l'attention du Président de la
République et puis s'il a la possibilité
de recevoir un millier de Mair demain il
aurait pu avoir effectivement trouvver
ce temps pour s'adresser au Mair parce
que ce qui compte c'est nous l'attente
que l'on a c'est est-ce qu'il a des
messages à faire passer est-ce que le
Président de la République a des
messages à nous faire passer dans un
contexte de décentralisation de
différenciation
d'expérimentation de simplification donc
l'occurrence l'interprtation il fera
peut-être passer demain soir il les fera
peut-être passer demain soir mais pour
le coup je suis d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit c'est confidentiel il
n'y a pas de communication de prévis
donc j'en doute j'en doute fort alors
est-ce que vous irez ou pas et bien
honnêtement je me pose la question parce
que tous les jours on nous parle de
aller vert et je crois que le président
ident de la République aurait dû aller
vers les Maes et donc finalement ça se
résume c'est nous encore qui devrions
faire l'effort donc je crois que je
n'irai pas si si vous me permettez je
pense que les maires ne veulent pas une
reconnaissance juste au mois de novembre
pendant 3 jours ils veulent une
reconnaissance toute l'année et c'est ça
ce qu'on attend et mais ça a pas changé
après les gilets jaunes ça de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron quand même il y a eu
le grand débat il y a eu on a une liste
de courses et il faudrait que le Cali
soit ville à la fin de de l'année ce qui
est pas toujours le cas ok Benjamin
Morel c'est effectivement on peut dire
que c'est pas une tradition républicaine
que le Président de la République Vienne
au au Congrès des Maires non si je veux
être très cynique la première erreur de
communication ça c'est d'avoir dit je
viendrai tous les ans sachant très bien
que quand vous êtes président de la
République c'est ce type d'engagement
vous pouvez difficilement le tenir de
manière régulière et mais qu'à partir de
là vous allez être attendu au tournant
le deuxième élément est queuse ltia est
très très fort en réalité le problème
pour Emmanuel Macron c'est les
intermédiaires et en l'occurrence c'est
la MF parce que la MF et bien c'est la
représentation en effet représentative
des différentes communes de France or il
veut choisir S ces élus Emmanuel Macron
il y a des élus qu'il dont ils sont
qu'il pourrait être proche et qui
peuvent lui permettre et bien d'avoir
une forme d'Ura territoriale mais en
revanche le fait d'avoir un
intermédiaire représentatif qui lui dise
ben non les maires en réalité veulent ça
ça c'est problématique parce que vous ne
pouvez pas donner votre vision de la
décentralisation on parlait tout à
l'heure de du rapport vert les
orientations a priori d'Emmanuel Macron
en matière de décentralisation sont pas
forcément celle prené par la MF par
ailleurs et bien le grand sujet
visiblement c'est de supprimer une
strate de collec ité territoriale
j'attends qu'on me dise comment est-ce
qu'on va faire parce que pour supprimer
le département ou la région faut
réformer la Constitution il y a pas de
majorité pour ça donc on va avoir
probablement un aè rapport de grandes
idées de grandes idées qui permettront
peut-être de poser une doctrine
d'Emmanuel Macron sur ce sujet mais
c'est pas la doctrine des élus et c'est
probablement pas quelque chose de
réaliste à terme en terme de loi votter
et donc ça évidemment bah lorsque vous
présentez face à la MF lorsque vous
présentez face au maire on sait vous le
rappeler oui F chap est-ce qu'il y a une
strate de trop une question que j'ai dû
poser ça fait malheureusement près de 40
ans que je fais ce métier c'est pas la
première fois que je la
pose je moi je ne pense pas qu'il y a
une serat de trop par contre je pense
qu'on va pas assez loin sur la
décentralisation je pense qu'on ne va
pas assez loin sur la simplification on
parle beaucoup d'allègement des normes
sur ce sur ce congrès et je pense qu'on
ne va pas loin on n'ose pas en tous les
cas sur sur l'expérimentation de mon
point de vue c'est plutôt ça qu'il faut
travailler et c'est aussi là qu'il y a
de fortes qu'il y a de fortes attentes h
je voudrais qu'on qu'on aborde un autre
thème dans ce dans ce débat c'est euh
les leçons des émeutes de l'été de l'été
dernier oui ont été tiré je je vous
propose d'écouter un témoignage c'est le
maire LR dererbly sur scène alors ça
date évidemment du mois de juillet après
une réunion à l'Élysée on écoute
Philippe
roulau le président écoute écoute
beaucoup en fait il a une il a une
grande habitude de de ce genre
d'exercice hein j'étais venu également
au au grand débat donc c'est bien de
nous donner la parole j'espère que c'est
pas juste un exercice de communication
et malheureusement je je le crains je
crois qu'il faut vraiment des actions
des actions concrètes pour nous aider
sur du court terme on n'arrivera pas à
résoudre le problème de fond de notre
société parce qu'on a vraiment un
problème de fond de notre société mais
sur des des avancées court terme on est
vraiment en attente nous les les les
maires de de décisions assez assez
fortes Franck Louvrier la la ville de La
Baule elle avait été plutôt épargnée
l'été dernier oui mais il y a eu autour
notamment à saint-nazer et à Nantes
énormément de difficultés donc moi je
pense qu'on on a là-dessus par exemple
sur le domaine de la sécurité on ne va
pas assez loin euh on a des opportunités
on a beaucoup de communes maintenant qui
ont des polices municipales il faut leur
donner la capacité à pouvoir mieux
travailler notamment grâce aux outils
d'intelligence artificielle grâce aux
outils de reconnaissance faciale les les
annonces qui avaient été faites pardon
de vous interrompre par par Elizabeth
borne il y a il y a quoi il y a 15 jours
c'est notamment dans dans sur cette
question là ça suffit pas pour vous bah
je pense qu'il faut aller encore plus
loin vous savez on le voit bien les les
tensions sont pas uniquement dans les
grands centres urbains maintenant c'est
dans les zones plus rurales c'est aussi
sur les littoraux donc tout ça fait que
on a on a vraiment là besoin de plus
d'autonomie plus de capacité nous à
décider parce que en fin de compte on
est majeur et vacciné maintenant les
maires on est capable de gérer nos
communes on est capable d'avoir les
outils qu'il faut pour pouvoir prendre
les responsabilités qu'il faut et on en
prend des responsabilités donc
laisseons-nous faire un petit peu ouis
sur cette question tient des justement
des polices municipales un autre
témoignage celui du maire LR de ne sur
sur marne pardon zartoch bactiar on
l'écoute j'étais venu tirer la d'alarme
j'étais venu dire qu'on avait besoin de
moyens fort de d'envoyer un message fort
à à l'endroit des délinquants j'étais
venu demander aussi un cadre légal plus
renforcé pour les villes qui ont besoin
de de se de se renforcer notamment
permettre à leur police municipale
d'être correctement équipé d'avoir des
drones qui puissent intervenir
aujourd'hui nous on met notre vie en
danger nous élus municipaux partout en
France pour aller faire des rondes pour
aller sauver ce qui peut-être sauvé pour
aller sauver nos mairies et et
aujourd'hui on on est souséquipé on est
livré à nous-même on est seul et voilà
donc je suis déçu Fanny chaapé est-ce
que par exemple il faut armer les
polices municipales et quelle décision
vous vous avez prise dans dans votre
ville alors après quelques heures de
débat avec la police municipale dans ma
commune nous avonsé de ne pas armer la
police municipale après on est sur un
territoire rural et j'ai toujours c'est
toujours mon fil conducteur moi
j'attends plus de la gendarmerie et en
l'occurrence on se rend compte que la
gendarmerie aussi parce qu'on est sur un
territoire plus rural manque de moyens
donc voilà je pense que si nous pouvions
accompagner davantage les gendarmes pour
qu'ils aient une capacité d'intervention
plus forte ça serait à mon avis une
piste à explorer et puis ce qui a été
dit alors là c'est le témoignage est
quand même très fort on se sent seul
donc il y a aussi un sentiment de
solitude et puis pour reprendre ce que
vous disiez vous avez parlé de plus
d'autonomie de plus de pouvoir et de
confiance aux élits locaux et je pense
qu'en fonction des territoires si nous
sommes en mesure d'écouter les mères et
de et d'écouter quels sont leurs besoins
et en l'occurrence un pouvoir d'agir un
pouvoir d'action qui est en terme de
Sécur Séité et assez fort et c'est à mon
avis le meilleur moyen une fois encore
c'est de de faire confiance aux ma et de
leur faire confiance en fonction de leur
territoire parce que certains vont
davantage demander de moyens sur la
prévention d'autres effectivement sur
l'action tous n'ont pas les mêmes moyens
il faudrait qu' une espèce de boîte à
outil mais dans tous les domaines la
sécurité la santé et cetera le logement
et sur les dans lesquels les maires
pourraient pourrai piocher donc plus
d'autonomie et plus de pouvoir aux élus
locaux laéticia vousouit intervenir i
que pensez-vous de la proposition de
David Lisnard il me semble hein de
former les maires avec le JGN
à la défense à l'autodéfense d' oui
c'est le cas mais c'est vraiment on
arrive à je dirais à la situation
extrême quoi demander au mer P se
défendre c'est que c'est SOS République
quoi je pense qu'il faut surtout donner
plus de moyens au m pour pouvoir
justement avoir des polices efficaces
moi j'ai pris la décision d'armer ma
police municipale en létal c'est-à-dire
en armement c'est eux qui sont venus me
voir en me disant Monsieur le Maire
voilà il faut nous protéger et moi je
suis parti un principe assez simple
c'est que je protège ce qui nous protège
donc nous avons engagé la
létal pour pour les policiers bois mais
mais je pense que c'est chacun a son
équation et j'ai pas g dirai de règles
c'est justement c'est que les maires
c'est ils veulent du coup humain ils
veulent pas une règle qui leur tombe
d'en haut et qui s'applique à tout le
monde on le voit sur la
nonartificialisation des sols qui est un
un autre débat mais voilà on a 450000
logements à faire en France il va
falloir c'est une bombe sociale à à
retardement qui nous attend si nous
construisons pas du logement il y a
urgence il y a urgence à agir parce que
quand vous faites pas le logement une
année vous perdez 450000 logements donc
il faut il faut vraiment se donner que
ça comme objectif aussi puisqu'on est
sur cette question des des violences
alors il y a il y a les émeutes mais il
y a les violences ou les menaces du
quotidien Benjamin Morel on a connu
beaucoup d'époques de violence politique
dans notre histoire et et et notamment
au au Parlement à l'Assemblée ou
ailleurs il y a eu des périodes qui
étaient presque pire que la nôtre hein
je vais pas remonter dans les années 20
mais mais est-ce que il y a un cran
supplémentaire qui est qui est en train
d'être franchi ou pas d'après vous alors
je vous confirme qu'en effet quand vous
aviez des têtes décapitées qui étaient
brandies sur des pics lors de la
Révolution française en plein hémicycle
la période était très violente on a eu
vous savez le le dernier duel en France
il est c'est un duel qui est un duel
issu de de parlementaire avec à l'époque
Gaston de faire donc oui la violence
politique ça existe ça a toujours existé
ça arrive de manière cyclique en réalité
c'est-à-dire que on voit ça dans les
années 1880 on retrouve ça évidemment
dans les années 20 dans les années 30 on
retetrouve ça au moment du mouvement
poujadiste on retrouve ça ensuite
souvenez-vous de Go avec un père on lui
crache à la figure hein donc c'est pas
si nouveau en revanche on a un retour
aujourd'hui de cette violence après une
période de relative pacification dans
les années 80 90 2000 et en effet c'est
inquiétant c'est inquiétant parce que
aujourd'hui et bien vous avez un
mouvement qui je l'évoqué tout à l'heure
est assez général dans l'ensemble de
l'Occident et donc on voit
qu'actuellement le politique n'est plus
épargné par la violence les maires
également et la société également moi je
veux bien qu'on donne ce pouvoir au Mair
pourquoi pas mais c'est un peu se
défaussé le rôle régalien en la matière
vous l' évoquz avec la gendarmerie c'est
celui de l'État il faut être extrêmement
prudent en la matière parce que si
jamais je suis une commune riche j'ai
les moyens d'avoir de la
vidéosurveillance j'ai les moyens
d'avoir une police municipale pléorique
et cetera si je suis une commune en
difficulté c'est moins évident je peux
avoir des aides de l'État de la Région
peut-être mais infin si jamais mes
administrés se sentent en insécurité il
risque de partir et on risque d'avoir en
la matière un pays à de vitesses encore
une fois les communes sont fortes quand
l'État les accompagne et quand l'État ne
se déf pas sur elle ça rejoint la France
en miette dont vous parlez dans dans
votre livre d'une certaine oui en partie
mais là je dirais que c'est une demande
même des communes des mer vous savez le
couple état commune c'est le couple qui
est le fondement de la République fan
chapé votre avis là-dessus je trouve ça
très intéressant est-ce que finalement
le le le jus C on peut aller en matière
de décentralisation notamment sur ces
questions régaliennes quel quel quel
pouvoir armement ou pas de la police
municipale et et cetera et cetera est-ce
que ça renforce pas l'inégalité entre
les communes finalement c'est ce que
nous dit Benjamin Morel ce qui enfin je
suis complètement d'accord avec ce que
vous vous venez de dire parce que un
État fort nous rendra plus fort c'estàd
qu'à moment donné il faut qu'on clarifie
où est-ce que l'État va quelles sont les
mesures fortes qu'il veut assumer je
reprends le logement parce que je veux
absolument que l'on en parle si on a un
État fort et si on avait des mesures
très fortes sur le logement nous les
maires nous serions plus efficients sur
d'autres compétences effectivement c'est
il s'agit pas de taper sur l'état mais
en l'occurrence de lui demander d'être
plus fort et donc quand je parle de
décentralisation c'est aussi ce dont je
parle c'est clarifion où est-ce que vous
voulez il s'agit pas les mères ne
demandent pas de la décentralisation et
ne demandent pas plus de pouvoir dans
tous les domaines mais en l'occurrence
s'il y avait ce dialogue fort avec
l'État nous serions nous où nous nous
positionner et c'est aujourd'hui cette
difficulté cette frontières qui ne sont
pas marquées qui créent ce malaise
parfois cette cette colère et comme on a
pu l'entendre dans les témoignages ce
sentiment de solitude et ça c'est juste
pas acceptable parce que à la fois les
maires disent on est agressé et dans le
même temps ils se disent qu'ils se
sentent seul et c'est une forme
d'agression de se sentir seul parce que
ben on on est démuni et on sait pas
comment se tourner on ne sait pas ce que
l'on peut appliquer on ne sait pas
quelle mesure l'on peut prendre et là le
danger pour moi il est là et c'est
vraiment ça qui est le plus à mon avis
dont on doit parler absolument lors de
ce lors de ce congrès ouais sur ce
sentiment d'insécurité résultat de
l'enquête du svipov pour l'association
des des maires de France 69 % des maires
ont subi des incivilités 39 % on étent
victimes d'injure ou d'insulte et 15 %
se sent en insécurité je vais terminer
là-dessus peut-être sur un témoignage un
peu personnel Franck l'ouvrier vous
l'avez vu vécu il y a vous avez déjà été
je sais pas menacé insulté oui oui j'ai
j'ai reçu il y a quelques temps une
lettre de menace expliquant que en en
recevant la la tête décapitée de Samuel
paatti et une image du Bataclan à
l'intérieur en disant la prochaine fois
c'est la Baule et et c'est vrai que
quand vous recevez ça à votre nom à la
mairie au départ je franchement je
voulais le classer sans suite d'une
certaine façon et puis je me suis mon
devoir c'est justement d'en parler parce
que si j'en parle pas on va laisser
faire des des des méthodes qui sont
inacceptables dans dans une démocratie
comme la nôtre et donc voilà mais je
pense que plein d'élus sont confrontés à
à ces menaces à ces tension et et c'est
notre devoir nous de de combattre contre
cette politique de la peur qui qui est
menée par certains et et qui veulent en
fin de compte anéantir la République
parce que c'est ça hein faut pas se
leurer derrière ça c'est c'est bien sûr
créer une révolte si c'est une
révolution dans le pays pour que après
le chaos puissent venir d'autres
responsables qui qui qui surfent
là-dessus donc on a on a un devoir nous
aussi de stabiliser tout ça et ça c'est
vraiment je dirais aussi notre mission
ouais allez un mot de conclusion même
question qu'est-ce que vous voulez en
dire c'est ce sentiment d'un sécurité
est-ce que vous personnellement vous le
ressentez aussi à pin Paul oui oui oui
j'ai également avec l'ensemble des élus
he on parle des m c'est l'ensemble des
élus oui j'ai j'ai été après il y a
aussi on en parle pas mais les réseaux
sociaux qu'il ne faut pas relativiser
hein qui sont un canal d'insulte assez
assez abominable et ce qui ce qui est
étonnant aujourd'hui c'est que il y a
deux réactions il y a les maires qui
disent on veut pas en parler parce qu'on
veut pas se victimiser et puis voilà on
veut pas être dans ce rôle là et puis on
nous dit aussi bah il faut il faut
porter plainte donc c'est cette
difficulté là c'est vrai que des fois on
hésite à communiquer et parce que le
risque de trop communiquer c'est de
banaliser finalement plus on en parle
plus les mères sont agressés plus ça
devient quasiment une norme mais oui
effectivement et c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure et j'insiste là-dessus
c'est aussi l'entourage familial qui
peut se sentir menacé et ça il faut que
les citoyen et les citoyens l'entendent
parce que ce n'est pas acceptable merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à à ce débat bon bon congrès des des mes
je vais rappeler le titre de votre livre
Benjamin Morel la France en miè je l'ai
cité tout à l'heure aux éditions du SER